pour ne pas être embêté,
j'ai donc conçu la tasse qui ne se renverse pas.
Elle fonctionne simplement grâce à sa forme.
La courbure du dessus renvoie le liquide vers l'intérieur à chaque tremblement,
le liquide reste dedans contrairement à une tasse normale.
L'astuce, c'est qu'elle n'est pas classée comme produit pour malades de Parkinson.
Elle a l'aspect d'une tasse utilisable par vous, moi ou toute personne maladroite,
et c'est bien plus confortable pour eux de l'utiliser, pour s'intégrer.
Et voilà un problème résolu,
il y en a encore beaucoup.
Je faisais tout ça, en parlant avec lui,
en lui posant des questions,
et j'ai réalisé que je n'obtenais qu'une information superficielle,
ou seulement des réponses à mes questions.
Mais je devais creuser plus loin pour avoir une autre perspective.
J'ai donc pensé à le regarder dans ses gestes quotidiens,
lorsqu'il mangeait ou regardait la télé.
Et alors que je l'observais réellement marcher jusqu'à sa table,
cela m'a frappée, cet homme qui trouve très difficile de marcher sur du plat,
comment monte-t'il l'escalier ?
Car en Inde, nous n'avons pas de siège sur rail qui puisse vous monter
comme dans les pays développés.
On doit vraiment monter les escaliers.
Il me dit alors :
« Je vais te montrer. »
Regardons ensemble ce que j'ai vu.
Donc, il a mis vraiment longtemps pour arriver là,
et pendant tout ce temps, je pensais :
« Mon dieu, va-t-il vraiment le faire ?
Va-t-il vraiment, vraiment le faire sans déambulateur ? »
Et puis...
(Rires)
Et le virage, il le prend si facilement.
Alors... choqués ?
Je l'étais !
Donc cet homme qui ne pouvait pas marcher sur du plat
était soudain un pro de l'escalier.
En faisant des recherches, j'ai compris que c'est à cause du mouvement continu.
Et voici cet autre homme, qui souffre des mêmes symptômes
et qui a un déambulateur,
mais au moment où il monte sur son vélo,
tous ses symptômes disparaissent,
car c'est un mouvement continu.
Donc le sujet était pour moi de traduire ce sentiment de monter un escalier
tout en marchant sur du plat.
Et un grand nombre d'idées ont été testées sur lui.
mais celle qui a finalement marché a été celle-ci. Regardons.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Il a marché plus vite, non ?
Je l'appelle l'illusion de l'escalier,
et en fait là où l'illusion se termine abruptement, il s'est figé,
ça s'appelle le blocage de la démarche.
Ça arrive souvent,
donc pourquoi ne pas avoir une illusion de l'escalier dans toutes les pièces,
pour le rendre bien plus confiant ?
Ainsi, la technologie n'est pas toujours la solution.
Ce dont on a besoin : des solutions prévues pour l'humain.
J'aurais pu facilement le faire par projection,
ou avec des Google Glass, ou un truc comme ça.
Mais je reste sur un simple dessin au sol.
Ce dessin pourrait être placé dans les hôpitaux
pour les rendre plus accueillants.
Ce que je veux faire, c'est que chaque malade de Parkinson
ressente ce qu'a ressenti mon oncle ce jour-là.
Il m'a dit qu'il s'était de nouveau senti comme il était autrefois.
« Smart » est devenu aujourd'hui un synonyme de haute technologie,
et le monde devient de plus en plus « smart » chaque jour.
Mais pourquoi quelque chose de « smart » ne peut-il pas être simple et efficace ?
Tout ce dont on a besoin est d'un peu d'empathie et de curiosité,
pour sortir d'ici et pour observer.
Mais ne nous arrêtons pas là.
Recherchons les problèmes complexes. N'en ayons pas peur.
Décomposons-les, réduisons-les, pour qu'ils deviennent bien plus petits,
puis trouvons des solutions simples.
Testons ces solutions, échouons si besoin,
mais avec de nouvelles idées pour s'améliorer.
Pensez à ce que nous pouvons faire tous ensemble avec des solutions simples.
Quel serait le monde si nous combinions toutes nos solutions simples ?
Faisons un monde plus malin, mais avec de la simplicité.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)